stories behind what we do in
ski racing and people see what
said something yeah he lives in
Finland yeah of course you know
so intense because they see me
at the start of a race and I'm
because people always they've
always thought I've been I've
a little bit behind the scenes
and behind closed doors and and
I wanted to give a little bit
more insight into what goes on
eighty-sixth and eighty-seventh
victory that just a couple
Yeah. Oh but the the rest are
like pretty goofy. So excited.
and coming to visit me always.
You know I'm a big fan. We all
Hope hopefully people laugh.
Hopefully they get some insight
there's just there's such a
lack of telling the actual
I'm focused of course so I
don't want to die but but when.
dropping soon. Yeah. Uh and and
I thank you for taking the time
doing that. You have a new one
coming out soon. I know I'm
the the details of this whole
season right up through the
what we do on on the slopes
when we're actually racing but
I have the skis. Yeah, exactly.
Think you can do it. Uh can we
Yeah, of course, you can host
if you like. You have the skis.
I mean, I I want to be you. We
all want to be you. We want to
year olds that want to be you.
Okay, MikaelaShiffrin. They do.
podiums every single race in in
all the disciplines and I I
be MikaelaShiffrin. Come on.
You're the you're the one we
Uh can you explain anything at
all? Where was this? In the
it's the most coveted prize
because it's the the sum of all
he won he won globes. He won
races. He was fighting for
mean each race has some like
medal or trophy or something
the do you say no thank you? I
bring them home and then. You
going with this. Uh a reindeer,
that would be the weirdest. A
said I wanted to be a rainbow
horse That was like my. Well
did the best in the world mean
to you when you're nine? Um I
I I read about you in a in a
journal when you were nine you
raise them like you're what is.
They're like walking around.
doing it. I mean, you're still.
It's wild. Yeah. It's a it's a
so cool. Thank you. Are are you
are you freaking out? Are you
salmon race of the season and
one of the prizes is a
What did you. It's in Levy,
Finland. That's the first
have a ton of these and do you
win prizes like this is this
excited. Can I move this out of
the way? Yeah, you can yeah
North Pole? Where were we? Yes,
it was in the North Pole. Yeah.
there. Why? I don't know what
you're talking about. You won a
weirdest prize you ever got?
Oh, I think I know where you're
Bowl or NBA Finals or whatever.
Yeah. Um this is what get at
the end of the season when you
are the greatest skier
mean this this was my big goal
for this season and I I crushed
it. Yeah it went well. Yeah
yeah yeah it went well. I mean
you. You're on top of the
world. Thank you for finding
bit like a bouquet of flowers.
Beautiful. No I I will move it
for bringing this but this is
just gorgeous. It's a little
them up. Careful. Yes. Oh my
gosh. Caleb, thank you for
throw them to the side. No, I
want that. We'll put them over
hold them? Well, really
depends. You could probably
Slalom, Dry Salem combined I'm
going to keep going. Okay,
out of the way but I'm just so
happy that it's here. You're
like are these something that
you would use? Um well yeah I
here. Alright, Katie, I will
put them over here. We'll lean
them now? Do I put them on the
couch? You could put, you just
want to take this. That is the
coolest thing ever. Thank you
World Cup overall titles. You
broke the women's record for
yeah. This season, you became
the first American to win 5
skiable. And I would use them
for free skiing. Uh thank you
each of the World Cup six
disciplines. Downhill, Super G,
show television. Oh my hey the
Okay. From the from the goat.
No you wouldn't race on them.
No I wouldn't. Would this be
would use them. I would I
wouldn't race on them though.
The Green Me Gives. Yeah, no,
okay. Thank you so much. This
doing this. Okay. I don't want
them to fall over. I'm going to
right along on YouTube. More
tonight show after the break.
Mikaelashiffrin, everyone.
Check out our series moving
are big fans. Congratulations
on an amazing thank you.
weeks ago. So yeah. I'm I'm
happy that you do that you're
into life and this whole
season. It really chronicles
the work that goes into it but
also the goofy side of it
Along. Yes. Uh what made you
want to do that? I think
talk about you have a YouTube
series called Moving Right
look up to. Well, we can trade
places one day if you like.
wanted to be like that. Be like
Bodhi. And now there's nine
kind of like entering the peak
of his career. Actually and he
yeah. And at the time when I
was watching him race he was
mean I my my greatest idol in
ski racing is Bodhi Miller. Oh
That's it. It's another prize
they give you. Yeah. Um what
you gotta you gotta have you
gotta go back to Finland.
man you you you did it a lot
for a nine year old but I also
you said I want to be the best
skier in the world yeah man oh
kids questioning yeah Rudolph
is real because I just like
he's because I named one of
them Rudolph yes and for any
your kids that Rudolph the
reindeer actually exists yeah
reindeer one by one. And that
now you can just tell all of
no, they say in Finland. I just
I'm kind of I'm like saving the
What do you. In my house. What
do you do with the reindeer? Um
reindeer. The prize is a
reindeer. What do you do with
reindeer? I won six reindeer.
reindeer? Reindeer, yeah. Yeah,
I didn't, I wasn't going to go
consistently through the
season. What's the what's the
the races in the season. It's
like it would be like the Super
but this is this is kind of for
me and from a lot of skiers
like would you win medals? I
obviously gold medals. We win I
I. It's all surprising. Do
would you do you win do you
weird feeling because I did not
set out to win 88 races. I I
enjoying this? Are you like,
wow, I've done it or I'm still
move it. I just want to even
just hold it. Wow. Uh this is
the time to do my little show.
I mean, Michaela, I'm I'm so
was set 34 years ago.
Eighties88? I mean, look at
for most World Cup wins
eighty-eight. A record 86 that
most career Giant Slalom wins
at 21 and You broke the record
about you. Uh you're the only
skeer to have won a race in
used to it. I know hello. Uh
can I to say some nice things
something that I would use?
Yes. Yes. Those are fully
frame these. Uh. Hey, it's. I
mean, these skis can I just say
had an incredible World Cup
season where she became the
so much. What do I, what can I
do with them? Yeah. Um. Can I
this is a gift I got from
Atomic on my eighty-sixth
name. Thank you right there.
Says the goat, the goat of talk
Victory just a few weeks ago.
Oh my god. But I want to give
you. I'm. What is this? You
brought skis with you? For you.
winningest alpine skier of all
time. Everyone, please welcome
Stick around.
like. No, I'm not going to use
them. I mean, what do I do with
Don't cut yourself. From the
goat. Thank you so much. No, I
em to you and get a little a
little engraving. Says your
This is a gift.
Look at you. Welcome back to
the show. I'm so happy to see
Mikaela Shiffrin.
Our next guest is a two-time
Olympic gold medalist who just